hawaii congresswoman current lieutenant
colonel in the army reserves hosley
gabbard as well as tulsi let me play a
quarter of you uh on jessie's show
and i want to ask you about it
central to that humility jesse is first
and foremost recognizing you're not god
you are not in control and if you try to
pretend that you are
what will result even with good
intentions what will result
unfortunately is more suffering more
hardship for the people in the world
that supposedly he's trying to save
so
i am a supporter tulsi of the reagan
doctrine and the trump doctrine reagan
doctrine is
providing stinger missiles to the
mujahideen when the soviets invaded in
the 80s they were successful they pushed
the soviets out
supporting the nicaraguan freedom
fighting contras over the
sandinistas and daniel ortega i'm also a
supporter of the trump doctrine which is
bomb the living hell out of people don't
put an american boot on the ground maybe
some intel boots there but that's about
it and with pinpoint accuracy push
buttons from all over the united states
and we'll hit any target we want we'll
blow the caliphate out of existence
trump did it solomonia for tarmac l
baghdadian associates and the al qaeda
leader in yemen it sounds to me
like you don't believe in that
we're not putting one american boot on
the ground and my argument would be if
we don't if putin is successful here god
only knows where his territorial
ambitions will take him next
yes sean you know all the things that
you just talked about and explained
there frankly our tactics those are
tactics to accomplish
what and and the what is really the
central question here that needs to be
answered is
what is our objective what is the
objective of the united states uh what
actions and objective best serves the
interest of the american people uh
that's the question that's the thing
that that president biden his
administration has failed to detail
outline or even identify and it's
frankly why we're seeing how he's at
nato right now trying to clean up the
mess that he made with these food
shortages and all these things coming
around as a result of the sanctions
policies that that he put in
that he put in place so any time you
look at so many of our foreign policy
disasters in the past we see they have
come about because our leaders have
failed to outline what is it exactly we
are trying to achieve and how does it
best serve the interest of the american
people will it ask the question
differently will it improve them or will
it actually make it worse and i think
that's really the central question let
me ask the question
this country needs to answer
you know does the world we can't be the
world's policeman you and i agree on
that part we can't
however
um we are a nation that has a conscience
and a soul and a belief in natural law
that that rights come from god not from
governments i think you agree with that
part
and
when you see entire cities like mario
paul
decimated
hospitals bombed out maternity hospitals
schools bombed out indiscriminate
bombing of innocent men women and
children and you see women and children
shot dead bombed out in the streets and
the cities of ukraine
does america at least have a moral
obligation to assist a country that's
willing to fight for itself to defend
their natural rights because that's what
reagan called the reagan doctrine
the role that we have and that frankly
president biden should have uh carried
out from the get-go in this and you've
not you i've talked about this with you
before is
doing
all that we can to try to prevent this
tragic war from happening in the first
place try to prevent i agree with that
but i'm looking at where we are in our
lives from being lost
what do you see in your own eyes
but what you see with your own eyes and
what we're showing every night
is there a moral obligation and is it
wise and strategically beneficial to the
world and including the united states to
stop this this megalomaniac murdering
thug right here right now with the
ukrainians willing to fight if they only
have the weapons
we have to look at the world as it
exists in reality not the world that we
wish existed you're done it is a tulsi
i'm asking a real question here
now i'm trying to answer your question
the cruelty is to try to pretend to the
ukrainian people that they are going to
win in a war against a nuclear-armed
country that is out equipped out uh that
has stronger equipment more tanks more
bombs more planes more people more
everything in russia it's just not
realistic
wait a minute
give them nothing because russia has
nukes and they might use them
that's your that's your
we've provided we've provided a
tremendous amount of support to ukraine
not only now but over the years so that
they have the ability to defend
themselves and the ukrainians should
give them the weapons so they can win
should we give them the weapons to win
the war if they're doing a great job
everybody acknowledges that
should we give them all
and europe too give them the weapons if
they're willing to fight for their
country
they can't win this war sean this is the
real world that we live in it is not uh
it's not strategically possible to think
that ukraine is going to beat russia
if you look at it and then what you're
saying is what is winning you fear of
vladimir putin
you're saying you fear vladimir putin
would use a nuke if he uses a nuke the
radiation
the radiation fallout will impact nato
countries that triggers article five do
you believe in article five of the nato
agreement i i think that i think the
most responsible thing that our leaders
the united states leaders of nato
ukraine and russia need to do right now
is look at what the reality is that we
are facing on the ground and the reality
that they want to be facing and come
together
okay
putin doesn't want to negotiate clearly
doesn't want to negotiate there's been
many attempts at negotiation so when you
see images of dead women
hang on you you do not think we should
provide them the weapons to defend
themselves that's i just want to know
yes or no
no my you're you're you're missing my
point here sean which is we've got to
know what we're trying to accomplish
which is an end to this war it is cruel
to make the ukrainian people believe
that somehow they are going to win this
war by prolonging it and that's what
you're talking about here it would
prolong this war prolong the summit
argument is
vladimir putin wanted to negotiate he
would have done it a long time ago he's
not willing to
and if and if he wants to use chemical
biological and nuclear weapons he's got
to know that his entire country is going
to be blown off the face of the earth i
pray to god we never get to that point
but that's always been a threat
and it remains a threat here and we
can't cower in fear based on the fact
that we've had mutually assured
destruction pretty much for all lifetime
but
i appreciate you being on good